So Moore's laws or the law of the
computer industry that says compute
power doubles every 24 months or so.
And you know,
that sort of put out there by experts in
technology development is sort of,
you know,
the prototype,
that's the thing that it really shoot
for more as law,
but nobody ever keeps up with Moore's
law.
It's up the computer industry.
So it's saying we actually track and
have been tracking really,
you know,
the past 15 years in terms of the costs
for Dna sequencing and uh,
trying our best to keep up with Moore's
law.
And we actually,
we actually did keep up with Moore's law
really quite effectively,
uh,
near the end of the genome project.
And even in a number of years for about
four or five years after the genome
project using the old fashion method
that we used to use,
um,
for DNA sequencing.
But we had sufficiently industrialized
those methods and it actually allowed us
to keep up with Moore's law.
And then what happened about 2007 our
major groups switched over to these
fancy new methods.
They're called next generation DNA
sequencing methods and almost overnight
and has just continued to do it up to
the present time.
They outstrip Moore's law by far and
it's really been truly remarkable.
They'll cost of DNA sequencing have
plummeted tremendously so that that
first human genome sequence that was
completed 10 years ago cost $1 billion.
And now we can sequence a human genome
today in a matter of a day or two.
And it costs well under $10,000.
Really just a few thousand dollars.
And if you follow the curves,
which we've been following,
you can see particularly over the last
six years,
we have outpaced Moore's law by far.
So among the many exciting developments
in genomics,
um,
really continues to be new technologies
for sequencing DNA.
We've come along way and have incredibly
powerful methods today,
but there's new ones coming and we
continue to invest in the development of
new technologies because we see the
importance of it.
Um,
there's a particular new methodology
that's getting a lot of attention in the
genomics community these days called
nanopore sequencing.
It really is just these molecules that
sit and lip ud by layers and the strands
of DNA sort of get pulled through it and
literally are able to detect every
single base on that DNA ladder.
One at a time as it gets pulled through.
The nanopore is just way cool.
But what's particularly cool about it is
that the technologies are,
can be reduced to really small form.
And one of the companies that's
manufacturing is releasing an instrument
this year that um,
uh,
basically looks like a USB device.
In fact,
it is a USB device a little bit bigger
than a thumb drive and literally it
plugs into the USB port of a laptop
computer.
And um,
I haven't seen it,
I haven't seen it operate yet,
but I'm told it can sequence a human
genome and something like a day we'll
have to see when it's released.
I'll how it really performs.
But the notion,
you know,
and whether it's that company,
whether it's this year,
whether it's another company that's
another year,
it's not science fiction to believe that
we will have these little USB devices
sitting in our laptop that can read out
human genome sequences.
And the next year or two or three.
One of the things I think is
particularly cool with this first
company that's launching,
um,
uh,
these USB devices is that the company
tells me that the USB device that it
will sequence a human genome will work
equally well in a pc or a macintosh
computer,
which makes me think everything.